J'espère que vous et votre famille
attrapez la maladie de Lou Gehrig.
Je vous recommande de tirer un sac en plastique de
votre tête et de l'attacher autour de votre cou.
Asafa voir la
voix ah
mojo dire ouais de choisir des chansons K facilement
media socio Moses a DiPaola considérer une
médecine funky soul un media socio donateur
un deuxième compte est kapahala Bob il ne
déduit que Vega Samba kulit lié au Népal
et une note d'Exeter ma te ataarangi kia
sedona bernie transféré mi security me
jeepers - lusaka de da de da de da de
hecho paralyser FM pass que yo le monde '
réussit madonna critique you Java
applet quel jour Missy des nouvelles sur Avon
si de la merde
le quoi le conservateur visite Milan à
un  entrepôt avec un v8 a une came bleue
libéral Parkin conservatoires Espace le
propre sur une ville morte parc du centre-ville
Mila travail tentative octa SSN condition
kong dois accepté
gossiped monde